we are back and 40 years ago y'all the
motherdaughter duo Naomi and wiona broke
ground in the country music scene as the
Juds they earned gramys CMA Awards ACM
Awards and we just love them so much
they were all set to do a reunion tour
in 2022 when tragically Naomi Jud passed
away to celebrate her mama's Legacy and
to raise awareness about mental illness
wona Jud has released a new album called
a tribute to the Juds the artists who've
contributed are some of the best Dolly
Parton Laney Wilson jelly roll and our
next guests performing the judge classic
cry myself to sleep oh you ain't ready
for this give it up for wona Jud and
Trisha
[Applause]
Yearwood so
hard you know I can't do
more it's the turn of the
car it's a close of the the
door the lies you
told you know they hurt so
deep so I'll go
home and cry myself to
sleep day after
day youve been treating me bad
my friends come up and they
say why do you take all
that it'sing
[Music]
me oh and it's making me
we so I'll
go and I'll cry myself to
see you love like a child G oh one day I
I'm out G you change the rules and I
just can't wait it's broken me now so
ioo get it
girl
but I don't know
what oh I gave to
you everything that I
got oh so take this
heart oh it's left to
keep and I'll go home home and cry
myself to
[Music]
sleep cry myself to sleep C myself
to all I do is
[Music]
cry
myself C myself
to
[Music]
sleep to
me
myself c c c c
c
th
C myself to
[Music]
S one more time y'all we were blessed
let's here for wona J and two of the
greatest singers ever as we honor
National mental Wellness month remember
to pick up the tribute to the wherever
you get your music a portion of the
proceeds go to the National Alliance on
Mental Illness Tennessee we will be
right back with what I'm liking
[Music]
[Applause]
this thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home